-Oh, you know what?
I have things
I got to talk about.
-What?
-I'm very excited about this.
'Cause I have a
production company.
-What?
-Do you know that?
-I do.
-At a certain point, people get
production companies
and they produce things.
And I produce these shows,
and now they're airing.
My production company,
first of all, is called
Electric Hot Dog.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. Thank you.
-Nice.
-So, we make fun things and
cool things and musical things,
things for family-themed stuff.
But get ready for this.
Wednesday, October 13th --
That's next Wednesday, is it?
[ Drumroll ]
-Sure.
-Next Wednesday,
October 13th, 9:30.
-9:30.
-On E!
-E!
-"Clash of the Cover Bands."
-Oh!
-Now, look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Dude, you're going to love this.
-Okay.
-This is my jam right here.
So, this is every cover-band
dream that you could think of.
It's gonna be
U2 versus Coldplay,
Dolly Parton versus
Carrie Underwood.
-And it's The Clash
that plays them?
-No, the band The Clash
is not --
No, we didn't book any
Clash cover bands.
That is a different show called
"Clash Cover Bands."
Where there are bands sounding
like the band The Clash.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. That is not this at all.
-No.
This is "Clash of
the Cover Bands," yeah.
We have Britney Spears
versus Jennifer Lopez.
-Ooh!
-Yeah, so, check this out.
tWitch is the host.
We have, as judges,
Meghan Trainor,
Adam Lambert, Ester Dean.
The winner of
"Clash of the Cover Bands"
gets like $25,000
or something crazy.
And they also get to come on
"The Tonight Show."
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Just saying.
"Clash of the Cover Bands."
This is next Wednesday.
-9:30.
-9:30 on E!
"Clash."
I'm so excited about this.
You know I love music.
And then they get to appear on
"The Tonight Show."
Speaking of "The Tonight Show,"
I have another show
that I'm producing.
-What?!
-Yeah.
[ Drumroll ]
-What's it called?
-It's streaming.
-Streaming? On?
-It's on Peacock.
-Peacock!
-October 14th.
Ladies and gentlemen,
get your kids excited for this.
"The Kids Tonight Show."
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ah! This is fun.
We got some of the
cutest, most talented kids
hosting this show.
Look at these guys.
It is the best thing.
It's "Tonight Show"
in like 15-minute chunks.
It's basically our show,
just without me.
Just younger people.
But it's still --
It's silly games, fun and games,
big celebrities.
The Roots came on.
Quest, Tariq came on.
We have -- Matthew McConaughey's
on, Kristen Bell.
JoJo Siwa came on the show.
All you have to do is
get the Peacock app.
Look at this. I did this.
If you don't
have the Peacock app --
-Oh, snap!
-No, it's not a Snap.
-It's not a Snap.
-No, it's not.
It's a QR code.
-QR?
-It's a QR code for the Peacock.
So, here's what you do.
You got your phone out?
Take a picture of this.
It'll take you
right to the link.
It's free.
You put your e-mail in.
Now you got Peacock.
And that's how you do it
and that's how it's --
Then you flip it up in your
stuff or watch it on your jam.
-Yeah, open on your phone?
-Yeah.
So, anyway,
that's it right there.
That's what I'm talking about.
"Kids Tonight Show."
That is on Thursday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Clash of the Cover Bands."
-Wednesdays.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
These are two of my --
I'm excited about this.
These are my jams right here.
-I can't wait.
-This is it.
[ Cheers and applause ]